what this machine learning in this video
we will try to define what it is and
also try to give you a sense of when you
want to use machine learning
even among machine learning
practitioners there isn't a well
accepted definition of what is and what
isn't machine learning but let me show
you a couple of examples of the ways
that people have tried to define it
here's the definition of what is machine
learning that is due to author Samuel he
defined machine learning as the field of
study that gives computers the ability
to learn without being explicitly
programmed Samuels claim to fame was
that back in the 1950s he wrote a
checkers playing program and the amazing
thing about this checkers playing
program was that Officer Samuel himself
wasn't a very good checkers player but
what he did was he had the program play
tens of thousands of games against
itself and by watching what sorts of
board positions tended to lead to wins
and what sort of board positions tended
to veto losses the checkers playing
program learned over time what are good
board positions and what a bad board
positions and eventually learned to play
checkers better than Arthur Samuel
himself was able to this was a
remarkable result also Samuel himself
turned out not to be a very good
checkers player but because the computer
has the patience to play tens of
thousands of games against itself no
human has the patience to play that many
games by doing this the computer was
able to get so much checkers playing
experience that it eventually became a
better checkers player than offered
Samuel himself this is somewhat informal
definition and an older one here's a
slightly more recent definition by Tom
Mitchell who is a friend out in
committee Mellon so Tom defines machine
learning by saying that a well-posed
learning problem is defined as follows
he says a computer program is said to
learn from experience II with respect to
some Tosti and some performance measure
key evidence performance on T as
measured by P
improves of experience II I actually
think he came up with this definition
just to make it wrong
for the checkers playing examples the
experience II would be the experience of
having the program play tens of
thousands of games against itself the
task T would be the task of playing
checkers and the performance measure P
would be the probability that wins the
next game of checkers against some new
opponent throughout these videos besides
me trying to teach you stuff I'll
occasionally ask you a question to make
sure you understand the content here's
one on top of the definition of machine
learning by Tom McCullar let's say your
email program watches which emails you
do or do not value spam so in an email
client like this you might click this
spam button to report some email as spam
but not other emails and based on which
emails you Marcus them say your email
program learns better how to filter a
spam email what is the task of T in the
setting in a few seconds the video will
pause and when it does so you can use
your mouse to select one of these four
radio buttons to let to let me know
which of these four you think is the
right answer to this question so
hopefully you got that this is the right
answer
classifying emails is a toss T in fact
this definition defines the task T a
performance measure P and the some
experience e and so watching you label
emails as spam or non-spam this would be
the experience e and the fraction of
emails correctly classified that might
be our performance measure P and so our
task performance on the task about
systems performance on the task T on the
performance measure P will improve after
the experience e in this course I hope
to teach you about various different
types of learning algorithms there are
several different types of learning
algorithms the main two types are what
we call supervised learning and
unsupervised learning I'll define what
these terms mean more in the next couple
videos but it turns out that in
supervised learning the idea is we're
going to teach the
how to do something whereas in
unsupervised learning we're going to let
it learn by itself don't worry if these
two terms don't make sense yet in the
next two videos I'm going to say exactly
what these two types of learning on you
will also hear all the buzz terms such
as reinforcement learning and
recommender systems these are other
types of machine learning algorithms
that we'll talk about later but the two
most used types of learning algorithms
are probably supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and I'll define
them in the next two videos and we'll
spend most as far as talking about these
two types of learning algorithms it
turns out one of the other things we'll
spend a lot of time on in this class is
practical advice for applying learning
algorithms this is something that I feel
pretty strongly about and exactly
something that I don't know of any other
University teachers teaching about
learning algorithms it's like giving you
a set of tools and equally important or
more important than giving you the tools
is to teach you how to apply these tools
I like to make an analogy to learning to
become a carpenter imagine that someone
is teaching you how to be a carpenter
and they say here's a hammer here's a
drive screwdriver is a saw good luck
well that's no good right you have all
these tools but the more important thing
is to learn how to use these tools
properly there's a huge difference we
can keep between people that know how to
use these machine learning algorithms
versus people that don't know how to use
these tools well here in Silicon Valley
when I live when I go visit different
companies even at the top Silicon Valley
companies very often I see people trying
to apply machine learning algorithms to
some problem and sometimes there have
been going at it for six months
but sometimes when I look at what
they're doing I say you know I could
have told them like gee I could have
told you six months ago or that you
should be taking a learning algorithm
and applying it in like the slightly
modified way and your chance of success
would have been much higher um so what
we're going to do in this class is
actually spend a lot of time talking
about how if you're actually trying to
develop a machine learning system
how to make those best practices types
decisions about the way in which you
build your system so that when you apply
learning algorithm you're less likely to
end up one of those people who end up
pursuing somehow for six months that you
know someone else could have figured out
just wasn't gonna work at all and it's a
waste of time for six months so I'm
actually spend a lot of time teaching
you those sorts of best practices in
machine learning and AI and how to get
the stuff to work and how we do it or
how the best people do it in Silicon
Valley and around the world I hope to
make you one of the best people and
knowing how to design and build serious
machine learning and AI systems
so that's machine learning and these are
the main topics I hope to teach in the
next video I'm going to define what is
supervised learning and after that what
is unsupervised learning and also start
to talk about when you will use each of
them